louis keumayou bonjour merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur rtl ans alors je ne
le dirais manuela concret reçoit
quelques-uns de ses homologues du sel en
marge du forum sur la paix en marge de
la conférence internationale sur la
libye car ce qui se passe en libye est
entre autres responsable de la
dégradation sécuritaire de tout l'âge
tout à fait le renversement de mouammar
kadhafi ya une dizaine d'années a été
pour beaucoup dans la déstabilisation du
sahel avec cette crise sécuritaire qui a
émergé elle a émergé 1 s'est renforcé
parce que le rapport de force militaire
a été déséquilibré et il n'a pas été
déséquilibré juste par des paroles ou
par le renversement de kadhafi il a
aussi été déséquilibré parce que la
france et ses partenaires on distribuait
beaucoup d'armes dans cette partie et
que ces armes là aujourd'hui sont
utilisés dans le sel par les terroristes
pour combattre les pays qui sont
légitimement installés qui ont des
pouvoirs plus ou moins légitimes mais
qui ont une légitimité et donc on ne
peut pas dissocier la crise libyenne de
la crise sécuritaire que traverse le
sahel aujourd'hui alors oui de choses
qui ne sont pas du tout aux 10 teintes
il faut également rappeler que paris a
entrepris c'était au mois de voir deux à
réorganiser son dispositif militaire au
sel on sait comment ça a été perçu du
côté malien un abandon en plein vol
selon les nouvelles autorités du pays et
comment cela est perçu du côté des
autres pays du sel
je crois qu'il ya un besoin aujourd'hui
non seulement de parler de la situation
au mali en termes de souveraineté mais
de parler de façon générale de la
configuration du g5 sahel comme une
faute politique et géopolitique qui doit
être réparée rapidement parce que je ne
comprends pas comment on peut
aujourd'hui estimé que la gestion de la
crise sécuritaire au sahel ne dépend que
de cinq pays quand ça touche et que ça
commence à toucher des pays comme le
togo qui vient de repousser une attaque
terroriste des pays comme le bénin qui
est plus proche de la méditer à 2 delà
de l'océan
qui est dans le golfe de guinée ou
encore comme la côte d'ivoire qui a subi
la même chose je crois qu'il faut
aujourd'hui faire en sorte que leurs
voies d'approvisionnement comme
l'algérie qui est très important dans le
dispositif soit associé à cela que tous
les pays voisins de la libye et de ces
pays là soit inclus dans la démarche
donc du sahara jusqu'à jusqu'au golfe de
guinée il est important que toutes les
énergies soient associés pour qu'on ait
un maximum de contributions parler des
mercenaires et dire qu'ils doivent
quitter la libye ou que le mali ne doit
pas contracter avec 29 c'est peut-être
bien sur le plan théorique mais sur le
plan pratique il est évident aujourd'hui
que la france est dans une impasse dans
le sel et que la meilleure manière de
résoudre ce problème c'est de
multilatéraliser la gestion du conflit
et de mettre en présence toutes les
forces qui sont capables d'apporter une
réponse convaincante
l'algérien ont cessé la plus grande en
puissance de la région notamment
puissance militaire comment jugez-vous
son rôle justement depuis le début de la
crise au sahel
je crois que l'algérie est restée plutôt
timide dans dans la gestion parce
qu'elle ne voulait pas elle ne voulait
pas être directement un être en
confrontation avec la france elle estime
que la france dans le sud dans son sud
c'est-à-dire au mali qui a un oeil sur
tout ce qui se passe chez elle c'est pas
forcément bon signe ça appelle à la paix
et de la guerre froide où les positions
géostratégiques permettait au pays sur
le plan militaire d'en contrôler
d'autres c'est à peu près la position
qui a été celle de l'algérie et puis par
la suite il ya eu cette implication en
direct avec le mali qui a peut-être
facilité également la relation avec la
russie puisque les deux pays aujourd'hui
sont à peu près d'accord pour travailler
avec avec des militaires russes
utilisez-les expertise russe et je pense
que de plus en plus on avancera vers ce
réalisme du terrain qui consistera à
associer l'algérie dans la gestion parce
que tous ces mouvements là ont tous pros
leurs sources en algérie alors très
rapidement pour parler en eu des accords
dieu désaccord entre paris et bamako on
en est ou de ce côté là on tend vers
l'apaisant on en est qu'au début
finalement
non je crois qu'on est encore dans une
relation très puéril entre la france et
le mali ou le premier ministre et le
président ont des échanges qui ont tous
sauf la dignité d'un de de ce compact
entre deux dirigeants d'hommes d'homme
d'état comme c'est le cas pour eux je
crois qu'il ya beaucoup de choses qui
doivent se régler en coulisses et qui
doivent se régler dans le respect de la
souveraineté de chacun malheureusement
dans les collèges etc et c'est en ça que
la gestion des affaires publiques entre
la france et le mali devrait passer à un
étage supérieur celui d'une coopération
franche et nette où chacun a son mot à
dire sur le plan de la souveraineté et
où on n'assiste pas à des crises
d'adolescence comme c'est le cas
aujourd'hui dans ce que l'on doit entre
le premier ministre malien et le
président français louis keumayou merci
pour autre éclairage rappelle que vous
êtes président du club de l'information
africaine merci à vous